un migrante que resultó herido luego de
un impacto de una piedra en su cabeza ha
sido retirado por una ambulancia tras
enfrentamientos entre la policía peruana
y los migrantes que desde hace 16 días
tratan de ingresar al territorio peruano
los migrantes bloquearon un tramo de la
carretera Panamericana entre chile y
Perú bloqueando la vía con piedras
basuras y otro tipo de desperdicios en
protesta porque la fuerza de seguridad
peruana no les permite transitar hacia
territorio de esta nación andina
producto de los reclamos las ciudades
entre la ciudad de fronterizas entre
tacna y arica han quedado con el
tránsito suspendido y por si la atención
no fuese suficiente un grupo de
comerciantes peruanos también armó otra
protesta a un lado de la vida Pero esta
vez contra los migrantes ellos señalan
que los reclamos de los ciudadanos
extranjeros les impiden circular hacia
la chilena ciudad de arica donde compran
mercadería y ellos están reclamando la
policía en estos momentos hace esfuerzos
para contener por un lado a los
migrantes y por el otro lado a los
comerciantes y Francisco le preguntó si
existen avances a esta hora del corredor
humanitario para los migrantes que dicen
las autoridades
autoridades peruanas y chilenas trabajan
para establecer acuerdos con lo que es
el corredor humanitario pero hasta el
momento no han anunciado avances
Mientras tanto el ministro de defensa de
este país Jorge Chávez ha señalado que
Perú no tiene ningún problema en brindar
aviones que permitan trasladar a los
ciudadanos venezolanos hacia su nación
pero señala el ministro de defensa
peruano que es necesario emplear un
mecanismo por el cual el presidente
Nicolás Maduro
acepte y autorice el ingreso de retorno
de los venezolanos a su nación